and as we've been talking about las
vegas starting to reopen there is a way
to actually you know
travel around town in style now jc is
live at all-star cars with some luxury
car rental options what you giving me jc
hey rocky just for you the rolls-royce
ghost
this is your car rocky actually this
could be anybody's car
thanks to all-star car rentals and this
is jimmy jimmy how do you have so many
luxury cars
how does this whole process work well
what we're trying to do
is uh show people that we can do a vip
experience from all of our backgrounds
here at all-star cars
what we want to do is show you that we
can do everything from
a rolls royce to a slingshot to a
ferrari
a lamborghini whatever you're looking
for this is i mean this is an
all the ultimate piece of luxury uh look
at the beautiful leather interior that's
not regular leather i believe the
rolls-royce is made out of
they use mole leather is what they make
very special the interior
and then the emblem the iconic emblem of
the roles what's the name of that emblem
spirit of ecstasy the spirit of ecstasy
this car could be yours how much does
the rolls go for someone to rent this
our cars range
from about 299 to about 19.99 a day
i believe the rolls is going for about
8.99 today all right lens come on over
here we got about 30 seconds
look at this we've got we've got
ferraris here you can rent this you
could be driving
this ferrari tonight and this is the
stingray the corvette stingray what year
is this this is gorgeous this is the
brand new
first mid engine corvette made this is
the c8 model
which is a 2020. someone watching right
now they want to rent the corvette this
weekend how much does it cost
this i believe is 7.99 a day 7.99 for
and you know what as you said it's got
it's got a front there's a trunk in the
front
and the regular trunk in the back you
can fit two sets of golf clubs in here
the cockpit is designed uh after a like
a like a
jet engine inside there the cockpit is
amazing all right we got to wrap it are
you sending it back to you guys in the
studio
i'm i'm in car heaven here with all
these vehicles i know you are i know you
are
great bring me back a g-wagon if they
have one just fyi all right thank you so
much jc we will check back in with you
during the 4pm newscast
all right now